بابا بابا
خمس سنوات لم تنسي عبد الحميد اليوسف
مراره فقد ولديه واقربائه في مجزره السلاح
الكيميائي في خان شيخون جنوب ادلب اسئله
ايه وياسر طفليه
قرب الحدود
سيطره قوات النظام على خان شيخون امالهم
طبعا نحنا بعد ما قدمنا لهم شهود على قتل
اطفال التوام واخواتي ياسر وعبد الكريم
وشهداء من الحي 93 شهيد رغم الادله رغم
الشهود
حتى اليوم نحن رغم الاثباتات والدلائل
اللي قدمناها للمجتمع الدولي التحقيق
لليوم نحنا قبور ليش لانه استولى عليها
بشار الاسد
منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيميائيه عملت سنوات
على تحديد هويه مرتكبي لها هجمات
الكيميائيه اليوم نحن المشكله انه لا يوجد
هناك محاكمه لكن هذه الجرائم لا يمكن ان
تسقط بالتقادم ممكن همم ان يتم العمل
عليها من قبل الاطراف لانشاء كيان قضائي
يضمن محاسبه المتورطين لكن اكرر بانه لا
يمكن ان تنتهي او تسقط هذه الجرائم
بالتقادم انما تحتاج الى بعض الوقت
لمحاكمه المتورطين باستخدام الكيمائيه في
سوريا
الوقفه الاحتجاجيه لمتطوعين الدفاع المدني
السوري ارادت ان تخلد ذكر من رحلوا في
الهجمات الكيميائيه في
كل عمليه
مماثله لتذكير العالم بما حدث وبينما تشهد
التحقيقات الدوليه تعقيدات كثيره تمر
الايام ثقيله على ذوي الضحايا الذين
يقاسون معاناه التهجير ايضا بعيدا عن
ديارهم صهيب الخلف الجزيره ادلب